some of America's hardest working men
and women are farmers and they are
feeling caught in the middle of her
president Trump's fight with China on
trade and they're asking the president
to rethink his position on the matter
before it's too late for them
correspondent Doug mackelway has part 1
of our series on the fate of American
farms
Douglas Coleman and his employees
arrived at one of hundreds of fields
they farmed throughout Virginia but the
wind means spreading fertilizer we'll
have to wait
unpredictable weather like this has kept
farmers looking up at the sky for
centuries but today they're also looking
towards Washington China has threatened
retaliation with the proposed 25 percent
tariff on imported u.s. pork corn
soybeans and many other US agricultural
exports it would put some people out of
business including maybe ourselves we
can't just keep going without noting the
looming trade war has rallied farm state
lawmakers who see widespread economic
damage to rural America if a trade war
erupts about one in five jobs are tied
to trade so we really feel the brunt of
that in our state in anticipation of
retaliation the administration floated a
trump proposal for softening the blow to
farmers he's asked the Department of
Agriculture to protect our farmers and
we'll present a plan on specific
specifics of that shortly but many
believe farmers want support not from
the government but from markets we need
China China needs us China is very
important to us
agriculture and it is my sincere hope
that this situation will be de-escalated
last week farm state lawmakers met with
the president warning him of the damage
to agriculture they came away encouraged
senator Joni Ernst was one of several
who coaxed the president to consider
rien gauging in the trans-pacific
partnership
I have long long been pushing for TPP
and I see it not just as an advantage
for our farmers and ranchers and getting
our commodities into the those Pacific
nations but I also see it as a matter of
national security
just days later the president broached
the subject of reentering and improved
TPP while still believing farmers are
willing to make sacrifices if it means
fair trade with China but there may be
some limits to how much of a hit farmers
will take 60% of rural Americans voted
for Donald Trump in 2016 in a new
election year where some predict
Democrats may retake the house
alienating those rural voters is not a
strategy for keeping the house
right part one of our series dud thank
you